p after england permanent secretary in
the swedish academy host got the nobel
prize for 2011 the lavell price for 2011
is awarded a swedish poet too much
throng strimmer the price to a swedish
person a swedish academy gives it to a
swedish portion don't they find that
controversial abroad what you think well
perhaps but one should also keep in mind
that it is now soon forty years since
this happened and the earlier instance
when a Swede received a Nobel Prize it
was 60 years ago so it's not that we
sort of spread them around on Swedes
every another year so I think we have
been quite thoughtful about it not being
rash in choosing a sweet he's a
well-known person in Sweden of course
and for you and me but we have viewers
and listeners from all over the world so
please tell me who is too much on strim
as I said he is a is a poet but he has
never really been a full-time writer as
such he has worked much of his life as a
psychologist he is born in
ninety nine and thirteen thirty-one so
he's 80 years old and he has been
writing poetry since nineteen fifty-one
when he made his debut and he has quite
a small production really you could fit
it into a not to launch pocketbook all
of it so he has a he has a very sparse
and very well contain production he is
not a prolific author water is important
seeds well he is writing about big
questions of course is recommended death
feelings writing about history and
memory and nature a lot about nature but
it is not these things are about human
beings observing them these enormous
entities and giving them life or we
becoming belittle by these enormous
entities outside ourselves but it still
still it's it's it's about death in
history and memory watching us creating
us and that makes us important because
human beings are a sort of the prism
where all these great entertainers meet
and it makes us important and actually
so you can never feel small after
reading the the prodigy or optimist
transparent he's also exclusive when it
comes his comes to his language is
method for us for instance are very
famous but it's not just a question of
being a very adept and putting them
together but they are an important part
of it the metaphors open up
speaking of the Internet lyst Rach
reactions to this decision of the
Swedish Academy is he translated to
other languages oh yes yes I would say
that he is one of the world's now living
poet that has been translated the most
here he has been translated into over 60
languages I don't know if I can name 60
languages if you if my life depended on
it so is well known among people who
read poetry yes he got a stroke a few
years ago so he can't really speak or or
perform anymore that that's true he lost
his ability to to walk and his speech
due to it to a straw straw if one has
hasn't read him before where to start
well there are a number in the English
like he's well translated in it can be
found in all major languages and pretty
recent additions in the English language
there are you can find now two very good
collections additions that people have
put together
poems from from his own all this
production one is called the
half-finished heaven and the other one
is called new collected poems or
something like that and both of them are
pure gold we are very good and I
understand it translates quite well
thank you dear to England for taking
your time to giving us this description
of the great poet Thomas trans tremor
you